Wilfried Stephen Hamlin age 25
William Williamson is 25
Wilfred Holland is 26 John Ian Rose age
19 king george v visited tyne cot
cemetery just after it was completed in
1922 and he like I imagine anybody who
has come here over the last hundred
years was incomplete
or at the scale of the place
as well as the 12,000 headstones there
are also the names of almost 34 thousand
soldiers carved into the stone memorial
that surrounds tyne cot cemetery that's
34,000 men whose bodies were never found
34,000 men who of course will never have
a grave of their own and that is just in
this one small corner of Belgium outside
the town of Passchendaele
an unknown soldier an unknown soldier
that one from New Zealand private e
Phillips age 20 private jaywalker age 30
from Yorkshire an unknown soldier 12,000
graves there are here and more than
8,000 that's two-thirds are unknown the
bodies were never identified
private H Warren from Australia an
unknown soldier private W Marsden from
Darby private Jake Richards in Canada an
unknown soldier an unknown soldier
another unknown soldier